تصل خارطه الطريق التي اعلن عنها الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد الى محطتها الاخيره وهي
الانتخابات التشريعيه المبكره منذ ان اعلن
سعيد عن اجراءاته الاستثنائيه في الخامسه
والعشرين من يوليو العام الماضي تغير وجه
تونس
كل اختصاصات المجلس النبي
كل اعماله
اجراءات قبلت بترحيب البعض ورفض اخرين في
ظل ازمه سياسيه تشهدها البلاد منذ بدا
سعيد تنفيذ خطته لتصحيح مسار الثوره
ومحاربه الفساد كما يصرح مرارا وتكرارا
المعارضون لقرارات سعيد ومساره واخرها
الانتخابات التشريعيه بداوا في تصعيد
خطواتهم بالفعل شهدت العاصمه مظاهره في
الاسابيع الاخيره نظمها ما يعرف بجبهه
الخلاصه التي تضم احبابا
نهضه الاخوانيه الحزب الدستوري الحره
والتيار الديمقراطي والحزب الجمهوري
الاتحاد العام للشغل بدا ايضا على المقلب
الاخر في توصيف الانتخابات
نحن مقدمون على انتخابات
بلا لون وبلا تعمل
جاءت
وليده دستورا لم يكن
كثيرون على هذه الانتخابات لادخال البلاد
في مرحله من الاستقرار السياسيه مقابل
خشيه اطراف اخرى من ان تعمق الانتخابات
التشريعيه مبكرا حاله الانقسام في الشارع
والتي تترافق مع ازمه اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
لم تشهدها تونس لسنوات
لا ما مشيتش شومان مشمش انا اتاكد لكل 90%
وعود فيها اشخاص حتى واحد اعطاها كلمه في
تونس ونفذها ايه ساعتها يحب يعمل يحب اما
نخلص اشخاص خير من الاحذيه احذيه بقت
بقدمه يعني
الشخص وجيب لكم
والله العظيم